in this lesson we're going to talk about
venn diagrams so you probably remember
venn diagrams from your math class and
you probably remember these diagrams
over here on the right so you can see
that there's a couple different things
that can happen like for example you
know this represents the universal set
so it's like everything
you know that you're working with or
you're dealing with and these here
represent like subsets of that universal
set and one scenario is that the two
sets could be
overlapping like this and so what you
have here is that these people in this
group are actually in both of these
subgroups okay so they're overlapping
and what we call that when they overlap
we think of that with the term and so
and means an intersection or where they
overlap in math when you see the word or
or actually means
union it means that you're combining the
two sets so it'd be everything that was
in this set plus everything that was in
this other set here but you don't want
to double count the ones that are in
both so or means union or both and means
intersection or the overlap and so again
you can see that it could be this
scenario here where there's some overlap
it could be this scenario here where
maybe there's you know nothing in common
these are called mutually exclusive sets
you know they're separate or it could be
such that you know one set is entirely
inside of the other set okay so some
different things to to pay attention to
see if you can do this example on your
own we'll go through it together it says
in a school of 200 students if 120
students take spanish lessons and 100
take french lessons
what is the minimum number of students
that take both french and spanish so go
ahead and pause the video see if you can
do this one on your own
the way i would
look at this particular scenario is that
there's 200 students if we were to take
120 students and 100 students and add
those together you can see that's 220
students which you know exceeds the
total number of students in the school
which tells me that there must be some
overlap between these two sets it would
be this type of scenario right here but
the question is is you know how much of
an overlap is there well again when we
add these together 100 and 120 that
comes out to a total of 220
which exceeds
you know the number of students in the
school by 20. so it looks like that at a
minimum there's going to need to be an
overlap of 20 students in this region
right here so the answer would be
20 students so again something to just
refresh your memory on and that's just
this concept of venn diagrams
and meaning you know intersection or the
overlap or meaning the union you're
combining both sets together but you
don't want to double count the ones that
are in both groups so definitely
important something something important
to understand for the act and i'll see
you in the next lesson